it has shot up the news agenda it shut
up the public Consciousness in recent
months in particular and that is the
issue of Youth vaping
so we'll be talking about the
government's ambition
to eliminate vaping amongst children the
risks that Vape imposes to children and
young people more widely
maybe we'll explore a bit about the harm
cause the children by vaping talk about
initial responses from stakeholders to
the government's call for evidence on
youth vaping and we have two panels
the first panel will finish at about 10
45 10 50 and then we'll move on to our
second panel which will finish around
half past 11 so members can go into
prayers and prime ministers questions
in our first panel
we have Deborah arnott who's the chief
executive of Ash stands for action on
smoking and health we have laranya
keslin who is the principal of Saint
George's Academy in sleaford and we have
Dr Helen Stewart who is the officer for
child protection at the Royal College of
Pediatrics and child health thank you so
much for joining us just before we start
I just wanted to ask colleagues if they
have any declarations that they wish to
make for interests
Caroline I'm a consultant pediatrician
and therefore a member of the Royal
College of Pediatrics and child health
lorania kazalyn is known to me as a
teacher and my head teacher in my
constituency excellent anybody else
okay I I would just put on the record
that I have a former public health
Minister and obviously have interacted
with Ash on many occasions in that role
and since although that was four years
ago which makes me feel very old there
you go such as life so
this issue
has gone right up the agenda as I said
as a constituency MP I hear about this
from
head teachers I hear about this from
parents I hear about this at home
it is right up the news agenda
if I might start with you laranya as a
principal of a of a school
would you concur that this is an issue
that seems to be on your desk
a lot more than it was even six months
ago and certainly when you began your
career
um yes absolutely I would say that um we
have a significant proportion of
students vaping
um and um that they're vaping regularly
and in some cases making excuses to
leave lessons to go to the toilet to
vape and so on and so forth
um and um yeah I think we have seen
across our catchment area significant
increase
um my head student team would estimate
the proportion around about 25 of the
students at the school are vaping and
the local police who we work really
closely with would Echo that from their
experience in the Market Square and so
on around the town and
contrasting that to a number of students
smoking cigarettes pre-pandemic that was
very rarely an issue in school so this
is a much bigger issue and
quite wide ranging so one example that
you know is not directly linked to
health but definitely impacting on
education is students vaping and toilets
saying off the fire alarm and so we're
having to interrupt learning on a
regular basis or go out
um I had two toilets that I knew
students were vaping in I was monitoring
really closely and I became really
concerned about interruptions to the
exam season so I had to change smoke
sensors to heat sensors really quickly
to prevent us being in and out while
students seeing gcses and a levels and
so the ramifications are quite Broad in
terms of an education setting and
presumably you talk to your young people
when you know you catch the vaping and
or you know they're a disciplinary
processes I'm sure that what
conversations are you having with them
about their motivation
um I mean I think it is
um very popular amongst peers
um and so
um I guess you know if you roll back
um 40 years in the same way as it would
have been um to smoke so the perception
that it's cool
um with
um you know being in in that group uh so
so that's obviously a peer pressure for
is a significant issue and then I think
once they're vaping
um the the level of addiction
um we're seeing is perhaps higher than
it would have been amongst smokers in
that we didn't have students leaving
lessons to smoke a cigarette you know
they might have one sneak in the in the
woods on our grounds at break time but
they would go lessons you know there
wouldn't be a thought to do that whereas
we
um have regularly caught students
leaving lessons to vape and so I think
it's that being able to just top up the
nicotine on a really regular basis with
vaping that you didn't see with
cigarettes that was thing as a contrast
in terms of the number of students
vaping and do you get any sense that
there's
smoking falling from The Vaping
um no no not so much I think the the
flavor element
um
is appealing and
um and you wouldn't get that with
smoking cigarettes can you give us any
examples of the flavors that you've come
across yeah and I think that is a that
is a concern I understand
um I understand the appeal of flavors
for people trying to to smoke smoke stop
smoking
um but I think the branding of the
flavors so I mean some of them read like
a sweet shop so gummy bear slushy and
that kind of thing but also unicorn milk
unicorn frappe and I don't even know
what flavor that is
um but it's it's clearly pitched at
um in my view a younger audience and I
would say actually unicorns
um you know they lose their appeal at
least by the age 15. I think that you're
talking even young teen potentially
pre-teen
um being drawn into that but I think in
terms of
um the popularity
talking about the flavors and have you
tried this flavor and have you tried
that flavor and I prefer this one to
that one is increasing the chat and in
the same way as if you want as a peer
group to get involved in a in a you know
a kind of social conversation and you
haven't watched the last episode of Love
Island you're kind of a bit out of it so
there is that kind of drawing in about
you know flavors of Vapes is a topic of
conversation okay and then just as
finally how old is the oldest pupil in
your Institution 18. right so presumably
everybody that you're talking to about
vaping is over 18. absolutely not right
so how are they getting them
um so
um I think a mixture of roots
um
I I mean
I think some are getting them from shops
that are not necessarily checking
um and I know that
um we work really closely with the
police I'm quite fortunate that our beat
Sergeant is a parent at my school so we
we have a really good communication
Channel
um and our head student team have fed
back
um shops of concern to the police the
police are raising it with trading
standards but that goes back as far as
December and tracing standards capacity
to act is so limited that they still
haven't
visited those jobs of concern so so
that's the sharp side of things but also
I think there's a significant proportion
of reselling so some of the a-teens
might go into a shop and buy legally
and potentially buying in bulk maybe 10
20 Vapes and then selling those on at a
small profit and those are being sold on
obviously to the underage presumably if
you found anybody doing that running up
running at that business within your
school what would happen to them um so
we've been we undertake searches and
liaise with the police in that regard
um and uh and
um there are a number of students being
monitored
um
you kind of have to catch them in the
act or catch them in possession of
multiple Vapes and cash
um and so but but we work really closely
with the police in that regard just
funny this is also coming through the
post yes they're they're ordering them
online is that fair I I believe so
um I don't know for a fact but I think
also they're obtaining them from other
sellers in the local community
um and and and the the children in
reality have no idea what they're buying
um and so
um we we've done a number of assemblies
and we've written to parents more than
once and um I worked with the police and
they wrote a letter
um to the parents which we then sent on
through our channels
um where they talked about students
who'd been using Vapes to vape what they
believe was probably THC and then they
collapsed and needed to go to a e and so
they wrote to their parents about that
and off the back of that and one parent
handed in five Vapes that they'd
confiscated from their child's bedroom
who they believed their child might been
looking to then sell on and the police
had those analyzed and the chemicals
that were contained within there was
very little nicotine in one there was
only hydraulic oil and anti-freeze
um and um Caroline's already in
possession of that
um that list of chemicals that were
found in five Vapes nine extremely
concerning chemicals including
trichloride the line which then banned
uh since the 70s really so
um a worry for me is that
um youngsters who aren't able to go into
a reputable shop and buy a regulated
Vape are in my view more likely
therefore
to buy a vape from somewhere where they
don't know it's kind of origin and so I
think they're a little more at risk in
that regard of a vape that contains
toxic flammable carcinogenic substances
um so you know that is a concrete
example of one parent who hadn't
confiscated five Vapes from their
child's bedroom and gave them to the
police and there were nine harmful
substances in the five Vapes thank you
it's very I mean you know you are
obviously okay I guess you're before a
select committee so you you've ginned up
a bit on this but you know it's very
obvious when talking to you this is
something that you're dealing with on a
day-to-day basis and uh you know I mean
I I'm not a head teacher but I'm
guessing you have one or two other
things to do as well as manage vaping
yeah on your young people so thanks for
giving up time coming down seeing us
today um
doctor I'm not going to bring you in on
this panel because I'm gonna you're
gonna talk doctor to doctor with Dr
Johnson in just a moment
um but before before that Deborah Arnett
from Ash
um what I just want to explore with you
relatively briefly is
cancer research UK say that E-cigarettes
are beneficial for those who have smoked
or they shouldn't be used for people who
haven't smoked as their long-term health
effects are unknown
some experts have raised concerns
cigarettes could be a gateway to smoking
for young people so was when I was the
minister we were very much of the vaping
was a way out of smoking the concern
is that it's a Gateway Inn
one study okay just one study found that
young people who used e-cigarettes were
over three times more likely to become
cigarette smokers than those who'd never
use an e-cigarette however other
researchers have said that individuals
who try you still gets are more likely
to ride tobacco smoking anyway and so
there is there is conflicting advice on
this do you have and can you give us any
sense as to where the current evidence
base lies on the ramp in versus the ramp
out of smoking where vaping is concerned
as you know we work very closely with
the academic community and we've really
been looking at this I mean Ash started
monitoring youth vaping in 2013 because
we wanted to keep an eye on what was
going on
um and uh what you point to is what's
called common liability teenagers who
take risks take risks so if they smoke
they may well Vape they may well use
illegal drugs like THC or engaging and
you know dangerous sex or drink too much
I mean there is a lot of overlap between
these behaviors what we can say is that
at popular Nation level in the United
Kingdom over a time when vaping has
grown dramatically we have not seen
children's smoking rates go up I mean
um I think if you look at smoking rates
in 11 to 15 year olds in 2021 they were
three percent
in 2010 before vaping really took off
they were nine percent so they've been
coming down year on year
yes okay so is there any
good research that you know of that you
could direct us to in our work that is
that is adding to that research base or
is because you work as you say closely
with Academia or or are you working on
any of that yourself
um I don't think we
've some children they
can get way out of smoking for others it
may be a Gateway into smoking but the
fact of the matter is that we're seeing
two larger level of use of of
e-cigarettes by children and we need to
regulate to control it what worked with
smoking I mean smoking rates amongst
children 11 to 15 were 19 in 1982. in
2000 they were still 19 we'd have lots
of Education
um we'd had you know campaigns we'd had
this and that but no regulation between
2000 and 2021 it went from 19 to 3 why
they were you know cigarettes were made
much less affordable
um they were put out a site in shops
advertising was banned packaging and
labeling the the bright appealing colors
we got rid of
um you know we need to do the same with
vaping we need to regulate to drive it
down the office for health Improvement
did their call for evidence on the 11th
of April 2023 that closed on the 6th of
June I know you responded to that
um and the public health minister
produced up I won't say an updated
Tobacco Control plan because it wasn't
but it was a smoking plan there was some
there was some smoking actions and money
for tackling illegal Vapes uh in in your
opinion
are the government taking youth vaping
seriously
as an issue
we first spotted the loophole which
allowed Vapes to be given for free to
children in 2020 and we alerted the
government and said action was needed
the government consulted on Tobacco
regulations in 2021 we put in a
comprehensive response together with the
Spectrum public health research
Consortium calling for a tougher
regulation of tobacco but also
e-cigarettes took a year for the
government to respond and they said the
regulations were fit for purpose
and now in 2023 we've got another call
for evidence now you know I accept that
between 2020 now we've had brexit we've
had covid we've had a ministerial
Merry-Go-Round
but still action is needed and it's
needed now the last announcement said
they were reviewing the regulations
as you know a cross-party group of MPS
put regulations
um as an on vaping as an amendment to
the Health and Social care bill in 2021
the government voted down the measures
to get rid of the attractive packaging
and labeling
you know not enough action action needs
to be taken and we have three top
measures that we think are absolutely
vital which we want the committee to
examine carefully and they are to put a
five pound excise tax on disposable
Vapes to make them less affordable for
children but also to bring them within
the excise tax regime which means that
border force and hmrc have powers to
prevent illegal Vapes from flooding into
the country and prevent their
distribution and sale last year hmrc and
Border Force seized over a billion
illegal cigarettes they don't have those
powers for Vaping it's all down to
trading standards who've seen their
capacity cut by 50 and the numbers of
trading standards officers cut by 50 in
recent years and I can see Paulette
there who used to be in local government
and she's nodding her head so that's
really important
um prohibit branding with appeal to
Children you know why aren't they these
bright colors sweet names and cartoon
characters they're completely
unacceptable I completely agree with
laranya there and prohibit promotion of
e-cigarettes in shops putting Vapes out
of sight and Out Of Reach of children we
held a round table for ohid the mhra
which is the competent Authority the
advertising standards Authority local
authorities and everything last
September when our surveys first started
showing significant increases
particularly in use of disposable Vapes
and I found my horror that the
advertising standards Authority has no
powers to control the way that products
are promoted in shop only to advertising
outside now that's got to be something's
got to be I mean you see these products
in chicken shots never mind mobile phone
shops you know they're everywhere
um pound shops sweet shops you name it I
mean it's just completely inappropriate
thank you somebody is making a lot of
money and we may well explore that but
in the meantime Dr Caroline Johnson
thank you chair
um daughter Stewart
um I brought forward a 10-minute rule
Bill beginning of February this year
asking the government to ban the
Disposable Vapes
um as a sort of a start on this project
of trying to prevent children from
getting access to Vapes the Royal
college has come out in support of that
could you explain why
um so the Royal College of theatrics
represents as you know 22 000
pediatricians and we've got had a lot of
them coming to us with similar concerns
the rest of the panel about
um vaping and we feel that banning them
um because we know that they are 70 of
the Vapes that children use are
single-use Vapes so um we know that they
disproportionately affect children
they're the ones that children pick
um and so we feel that removing them as
an option
um is a much quicker easier
straightforward way of protecting the
health of children and we know that
um
sorry excuse me
um we know that they also have a really
detrimental effect on the environment
um because and that's another concern to
children we see a lot of children with
mental health problems that relates to
eco-anxiety and 1.3 million disposable
Vapes are got rid of every week just
thrown into the bins they're very
difficult to recycle the batteries are a
fire risk they contain lithium which
could be used for car batteries and the
the liquids in them are quite toxic and
I saw the chief medical officers report
that showed that they have some lead and
nickel in them and that's just leaking
out into the environment so
um there's a twofold reason really why
we think just Banning these and removing
them as a product particularly given
there is a a large number of smoking
cessation tools including reusable Vapes
out there we feel that it's not really a
necessity for there to be a disposable
option
thank you I I of course agree completely
with that not surprisingly
um
the industry often say these products
are 95 safe that's based on public
health England Document from from more
than a decade ago which was questioned
uh in terms of ferocity even at the time
in even at 2015 by editorial in the
landsat so
do you think that evidence still Bears
up and do you think it really can be
Quantified in that way
um short answer no
um vaping was introduced in the UK in
2007 so it's only been around for about
16 years so 10 years ago they couldn't
possibly have known the long-term health
effects of vaping
um we're certainly seeing an increase in
um
asthma wheeze bronchitis type
presentations that can be linked to
vaping and there's a lot of emerging
evidence about other potential
um complications but the reality is we
just don't have enough long-term data
and we'd much rather ban them now than
wait for 30 years it took to understand
the effect of smoking when we're already
the it's floating the chickens flowing
The Coop it's too late to roll back at
that point and going back to what a
brand new thing about the toilets a
colleague of mine is and runs asthma
clinics and he has many patients saying
they just can't use the toilets at
school because
um there's a lot of kids in there vaping
and it sets off their asthma so it's
it's a real and present would present
health issue for a lot of children and
young people
okay you talked about the more recent um
evidence and your
um your submission to the consultation
includes a document by Banks
e-cigarettes and health outcomes a
systematic review published in March
2023 looking at more than 400 health
articles their conclusions on vaping are
pretty damning can you tell us more
about those
um so I've not seen that
um report recently but um we know that
um
it's just it the evidence that they've
um they've gone through is it's all
emerging we it's all emerging evidence
that they um
increasingly we are finding that there
is just a significant health risks and
um
we we really need to have some more
long-term evidence before we can say
that these are safe and we just don't
want to wait we want to ban them now
yeah so that abstract talks about
um concludes there is conclusive
evidence linking e-cigarette use with
poisoning immediate inhalation toxic
toxicity including seizures and
e-cigarette or vaping product Associated
use lung injury and barley largely but
not exclusively for at least
particularly e-liquids and they talk
about the environmental effects they
talk about dependence and addiction
non-smokers and the Gateway uh to
smoking
um so overall quite a lot of problems
there's also evidence from Harvard and
California linking it with bronchitis
and emphysema a little bit more about
the effect on children's lungs of using
these products yeah so there's been um
some suggestion of some um young people
developing something called popcorn lung
um secondary to vaping
um again it's small numbers so it's
difficult to draw why conclusions around
them but it's enough to make us very
concerned
um I mean I work in an emergency
department and the toxicity of some of
these we see when children unfortunately
toddlers get a hold of them and drink
them and the toxicity is
incredible and we see some very sick
children so anything if that's that
toxic when you ingest it when you
breathe it in it's got to raise concerns
um so whilst yeah the evidence would
it's difficult to extrapolate but and it
is small numbers but it definitely
suggests a significant health impact one
of the challenges with assessiness is
that they're so varied aren't they so
um with the
the industry will say well we've taken
out the tar some of the other toxic
chemicals from a cigarette so it must be
better for you but they've added instead
chemical you know chemical flavorings
and other products to replace that when
children are as lewani described using
different flavors on different days and
comparing them it becomes more difficult
doesn't it to work out what the
long-term health effects of given
flavors are very difficult and there's a
couple of issues one is obviously
um that was also already mentioned
there's a lot of illegal Vapes that come
into the country and because of the
marketing it's very difficult actually
to identify which is
um which is illegal and which isn't and
obviously there's no regulation on on
what is coming in and so it's it's
impossible to say that um that they're
safer and also as I said the toxicity of
drinking them is huge so we can't
it's impossible to um to say that they
are safe
okay
okay thank you for that we may come back
to you um if you wish to uh Paulette
Hamilton do you want to come in next
um I have to say I was hoping I could
disagree with what's been said by the
panel so far but I have to say that I I
don't disagree with anything you say
the issues I have is um you have vaping
many of our young people don't know
what's in the Vapes that they take in
which you articulate you articulated
really well
so lots of them are having they're
having nicotine they're still taking
nicotine directly into their system you
then have the long-term effects from
that of the effects from nicotine
these children or young people I don't
like to say children are a lot younger
that are starting to vape even though
they're not supposed to be you've got
countries that are absolutely sending it
here in masses with all sorts of
foolishness in it it's not regulated do
you not think it would be better rather
than encouraging people to vape rather
than smoke
to say ban the whole lot whether it be
um
the ones that you can refill or the
single-use ones till you do get proper
regulation trading standards are that
bit of it is sorted out and some of the
things that you talked about Deborah is
sorted out then introduce it in a more
measured way because I've done campaigns
with Ash
and I love what they're doing I love
what they're trying to do the problem I
have is we're saying one thing on the
one hand but then we're agreeing with
something on the other hand which
unfortunately is creating a problem do
you believe that perhaps it might be
better for us to come together look at
Banning vaping to start with till we
have proper regulations and the proper
things in place where like cigarettes we
can remove it far more quickly than we
can at the moment because every time the
canary is selling it with God knows what
is in it sometimes assuming you're
coming to me on that person I'm gonna
come to you but then I'm gonna come to
Ellen I know what Ellen's gonna say but
because I have a lot of respect for you
Deborah I'm gonna come to you first
because I've read your notes here and
I'm a little bit worried about all the
considering some of the stuff you had me
doing not you personally over the last
couple of years to support what happened
I think it's really important we we we
want to protect children from from
smoking and vaping and we want to drive
down smoking which is still one of the
leading causes of preventable death in
this country killing you know and
responsible for half the difference in
life expectancy between rich and poor
now in Australia they've done what
you've suggested you can only get Vapes
on prescription what's happened to
smoking rates they've gone up
and does it make any sense to ban
something which we know is less harmful
the the argument about 95 95 is far too
specific but we do know that the
biomarkers of toxicity
um from vaping compared to smoking are
95 lower roughly that's order of
magnitude
um as people have said you've got to
wait till you you know the longer term
but there is a significant reduction in
the level of toxins the fact that you
don't know I need to bring you back to
that the fact that you don't know what's
in a lot of these products because
they're coming from countries that are
not regulated they're being sold in
shops that are not being monitored
because we haven't got enough of these
people I don't think you can actually
say that and then completely Paulette
you would just drive it into the illicit
market and that's where you can't
control it that's why we want to see an
excise tax and why we want to see hmrc
and Border Falls put in effort into
preventing these illegal Vapes flooding
on the UK Market Banning them isn't
going to help I mean they ban smoking in
Bhutan and smoking rates amongst
children went up in Australia they ban
Vapes except for getting them on
prescription and their smoking rates
have gone up year on year when ours have
gone down I don't think Banning is the
solution we need to properly regulate
so how are we going to support schools
to be able to control it and young
people that are in Care Homes at the
moment that are absolutely addicted to
this product and we are then saying to
them don't smoke but vape and our
schools and our care rooms are
absolutely they've got their own crisis
going on yeah well my my answer would be
we need proper enforcement and that's
not just relying on trading standards we
need to bring a bigger um
set of organizations to bear and the
ones that have the money and the
capacity I mean hmrc has fiscal crime
liaison officers overseas who examine
and what's going on in the illicit
market and stock cigarettes from
actually ever reaching our borders
be great if they could do the same thing
for Vapes but just Banning them they
will go under underground and there will
be an even bigger problem and an even
bigger problem with quality
there we know
um Dr Ellen thank you
um so I think once you've got
um a product on the market it's really
difficult to roll back and as um you
mentioned Australia are Banning them
completely and we're going to be really
interested to see the results of that
over the long term and that might be
something we think about in the future
but our priority as a college is child
health and we want to strike a balance
with allowing
um adults to have access to smoking
cessation products obviously we know the
dangers of smoking whilst protecting
child health and we see Banning the
disposables as a great first step in
that direction so um as a kind of
until we know more about the effects of
complete band we just think um Banner
the disposables is a good compromise
um
I'm really interested to see what you've
got to say how do you think this would
help a school like yours that's really
battling
um against the tide at the moment
I mean I think
um
you know I think a significant
proportion of the youngest youngest
children in the school who are vaping
um they're all they're already obtaining
them
via means other than going into a shop
that's following the regulations
properly and checking ID and so on and
so forth and so you know I I think it's
looking for all those unintended
consequences
um and and you know making sure that we
don't solve one problem and create
another so it is difficult but the the
ready availability to children who are
underage and significantly underage
um is a real concern and I think
um pricing the youngsters out of the
market would be a great first step
um and
um yeah I think I think that's at the
very least what I would say
um and I know that Deborah said around
you know if we roll back and when I was
at school in the 80s it was probably
about 19 of people smoking I think we're
all crystal clear that vaping is better
than smoking I think there's no debate
over that
um but what I would say is that the the
rate in which the number of teenage
Vapors is increasing I think is really
significant and so
um and it's difficult to get harder data
on that but um you know my head student
team and the police were concur there's
around one in four and increasing
um so kind of where does that stop and
the perception that it's safe so why are
all these grown-ups making a fuss about
it you know children are quiet would be
quite dismissive
um of the reasons against there are
there are more children so um you know
in terms of information assemblies that
we've had where they mentioned popcorn
lung and they mentioned brain
development and so on and so forth there
are more children thinking twice
um but I certainly feel that we've not
hit a peak on team vaping on its current
trajectory and I don't know where that
will Peak so that's a worry for me
um but also you know I mean Caroline
I've talked and as far as I'm concerned
the best thing to breathe into your
lungs is clean air
um and you know and and I'm no scientist
um but you know if you're vaping in um
you know you're taking in a liquid
particles in a vapor format and the
lungs are absorbing the nicotine what
else are they absorbing and we just
don't know and uh you know and I think
it's a real worry that you know we're
already 16 years into vaping in this
country and the trajectory is going like
that and and where do we end up and at
what point do we find out
um you know what else is being absorbed
into the body and you know and these are
not things that that you know may cause
you know sudden
um
medical issues it may take you know 10
20 30 years for those medical impacts of
vaping to emerge and we just don't know
that's the bottom line isn't it we just
don't know at this point but what's does
concern me is that the rate of increase
of teenagers taking up vaping and you
know and many of these lovely lovely
students who I don't think would ever
dream of
um smoking you know going and having a
sneaky cigarette they wouldn't do that
but they've been drawn into vaping much
more easily because it's perceived to be
safe and because of the chat around the
flavors and being in and being able to
be part of those peer-to-peer
conversations you need to be in that
crowd
um so so those would be my ways
thank you thank you so much for the
evidence today
um so we're clear about flavors we're
clear about colors and shapes and all
sorts of things that we need this clean
approach plain packaging and good Public
Health warnings on that
when it comes to revenue
um first of all
um if we're going to increase Revenue as
suggested
um five pounds you're suggesting is that
going to change the revenue on
cigarettes as well will that have to go
up proportionately how do you see the
equation between smoking and vaping if I
can put that to you ever very good
question
um I mean we already have some of the
most expensive cigarettes in the world
but
um uh what we're proposing and five
pounds may seem random we chose it
because when I looked at what Vapes were
going for Elf bar the most popular with
children half all children say that's
the brand they use
you can get them for 2.99 and the same
product which is rechargeable reusable
is um 7.99 so by putting five pounds on
you're making it the same prices a
rechargeable reusable equivalent and
that we think we know children very
price sensitive so that will have a big
impact but it will also mean that
they're not that actually there's an
incentive for adult adults who Vape to
switch to a reusable product where
they're vaping disposables but they're
still lower than the equivalent packet
of cigarettes which is about
um well I think they're between 10 and
12 pounds now you can get them online
for
it should reusables also serve Avenue
increase alongside that
at the moment no but I think that's
something that needs more detailed
analysis by um the treasury the reason
why I another reason why I think excise
tax is a good idea not just because of
the Enforcement issue which I think is
really important but also I mean we know
from covid Finance bills can move
through Parliament quite quickly much
more quickly than a ban on disposables
or
um you know doing something about the
advertising promotion in shops or the
packaging and labeling
um and
um you know finance bill doesn't require
the same sort of impact assessment or
anything else so it could be done quite
quickly relatively and it would have a
Major Impact we know from research done
in a number of countries that children
are very price sensitive to the to the
price of
e-cigarettes as they are for the price
of tobacco may also ask about products
which have no nicotine in whatsoever
would they also as you envision follow
the same course
um that's a very good question
um and I think we certainly want you
know one of the problems with the
regulations to date is that non-nicotine
containing E-cigarettes are not covered
so the you know there are regulations
about what the flavors can contain and
you know toxic carcinogenic substances I
mean the substance that calls pop causes
popcorn long lung or supposedly does in
large quantities in popcorn factories is
illegal in UK
um sounded Vapes
um whereas flavors in E-liquid which is
doesn't contain nicotine there's no
regulation
um there's no regulation of the
marketing you know so I think we do need
to look at how the regulatory framework
covers non-nicotine containing products
as well and also other nicotine products
nicotine pouches are beginning to take
off and we've been calling on the
government to act on those because they
are not covered by any regulations at
the moment and some of them have very
very high levels of nicotine and whereas
when you're inhaling something you can
you can respond to the impact that
nicotine has on your body fairly quickly
when you've got something in your mouth
and you're sucking it
um you know it's a bit the difference
between smoking cannabis and edible
cannabis where people can end up eating
enough cannabis to cause serious
problems because they didn't realize how
strong it was and the same is true with
nicotine pouches thank you for for
raising this as well with regards to
regulation around the strength and the
substance within
um Vapes
um do you believe that the cap of 20
milligrams is too high and that should
also be reduced or is there evidence to
say that that is actually at the right
level but the cap was chosen because at
the time it was the uh level that was
um you know the vast majority of people
who were vaping or vaping actually it
was 18 milligrams or less so 20
milligrams sort of slightly above that
in America they don't have a cap and
actually there's no evidence that
um children using Vapes in the US are
becoming heavily dependent even though
you can buy them in fact the standard
seems to be 50 milligram per ml or 5
instead of 20 milligram per mil or two
percent
um I mean the problem is if you bring
down the nicotine level
um people are addicted to nicotine are
looking for a certain level of nicotine
and they'll just Vape more if there's
not sufficient nicotine so I I don't
think that the 20 milligram per ml limit
should be brought down it should be
looked at but it shouldn't be brought
down one of the things that could also
be looked at from the environmental
point of view is the the size of
um the um points and the size of refill
containers because they're quite small
and that doesn't necessarily make them
safer
but it does mean that you have to use
more and from an environmental
perspective that's not a good thing
in the same way there could be a
limitation on the number you purchase
they could be on the number of PODS that
you purchase there as well
Helen can I just turn to you on that
same question around the regulation of
the substance and whether or not you you
believe that that 20 milligrams
um
per milliliter is too high or should be
reduced
um so that's not something that we
really focus on at the college because
it's it's related to adult smoking
cessation as well and for us I think any
nicotine is too much for any child to be
inhaling in inhaling and vaping so I
think
um we would we would really just once
zero nicotine for any child so ideally
if we could see these bands that would
be fantastic cute and and one last
question for you and it's my last
question I mean it's very clear that the
industry are trying to generate a new
generation of addicts that's what the
industry has been in for a very long
time it knows the subtleties of how to
achieve that
um what interventions can be brought
about which change the habitual
behaviors which it induces and to change
the way that
um clearly they're often responding to
stimulus and stress and all sorts of
things as well as all the things that
we've identified around peer pressure
and looking cool what additional support
can young people have so as not to go
down the line of vaping
um so in so in terms of for children
young people to stop them vaping in the
first place so yeah it's kind of getting
into the the behavior or even in once in
that behavior than being able to be
sported out of that okay so
um
like so for as a college we think
Banning them would really in fact impact
um a children's behavior and we were
aligned with us in many many factors as
well in terms of the marketing plane
packaging we know that putting
cigarettes behind the um the barriers in
in supermarkets and made them a lot less
visible
um has been a huge um has a had a huge
impact on smoking rates
um I was saw a sweet shop the other day
and it was called Over the Rainbow and
it was definitely for children but had a
big vaping stand outside so a lot of
these kind of things really do influence
children they walk past they see Suites
they see vaping it's all in the same
place and they associate it in their
mind so I think there's a a lot of um a
lot of these kind of things can help but
um but the reasons that children stop
smoking as well as the peer pressure and
all that kind of thing is also things
like mental health support
um General Health support poverty all
these things and play a huge impact on
the decision for children and adults to
start smoking so we would also like to
see action on a range of these things as
well thank you
right did you want to conclude on this
Caroline thank you thank you yeah please
I've got a couple a couple of questions
um
the
um UK via which we will hear from
in their submission
say that 83
83.8 of uh children young people have
either never tried or are unaware of uh
electronic cigarettes and vaping the
health work study found that 10.8 of 10
11 year olds had Vaped or sometimes
raped and 19 of 12 to 13 year olds and
42 and a half percent of 16 to 17 year
olds which of those
um views most current most closely
aligns with your experiences of children
vaping and start with the perhaps with
the lorenia the latter without a doubt
getting Dr Stewart yeah
thank you could I just come in on that
because I think I don't think any one
survey can show exactly what the levels
are because different surveys have
different strengths and weaknesses
um but what I think is really important
and that's why we started monitoring in
2013 is to look at Trend and what we're
seeing is a growing Trend and we're also
seeing growing experimentation and
that's you know rather than saying it's
this percent or that percent I think
that's the thing we need to focus on is
we need action because we're seeing a
growing number of children experimenting
I would agree we definitely need some
serious action on it the other question
wants to pick you up on Dr Stuart you
talked about students being triggered in
the asthma by going into school toilets
finding people vaping in there and that
kind of fog of sweet flavor that hangs
around
um
would you support a ban on these being
used in public areas anyone you get on
the train it says please don't smoke or
vape and that's that's common to a lot
of public areas but what do you support
that vaping being included in the
legislation that bans tobacco smoking in
public areas like clubs pubs bars those
sort of places I think that's something
we definitely would support we know that
the effects are passive as well as from
active smoking so that's definitely
something that we would support okay and
my final question was about the effects
of nicotine
you tell us more about the effects of
nicotine on the developing brain and
also whether you're seeing children who
are looking for support in kicking this
addiction because they've become
addicted to Vapes they no longer want to
spend this sort of money on it
um so on the second Point yes we have
our trust recently introduced a smoking
cessation service
which including nicotine addiction from
various products and now that is
um
also to help parents because we know the
impact of passive smoking but we are
also seeing some under 16s being
referred to the surface but a lot are
not in a
um they don't necessarily realize the
impact of the or necessarily acknowledge
their addiction at their at their young
age so it's very hard to
um
we know that children young people have
different attitudes to risk-taking
behavior different understandings of
um they find it very difficult to
appreciate the long-term impact of some
of their actions so
um we we don't get that many who
acknowledge that there's a problem and I
think that's one of the difficulties and
that's why we're so Keen to see a band
because actually young people just don't
have the
um capacity to understand the long-term
consequences of their decisions in the
same way and we know that nicotine has
an effect on the detrimental effect on
the developing brain and the teen years
are a key point of development in terms
of future attitude so
um it's quite significant and again why
we'd love to see it back we do need more
education at that particular point
because I think it's quite an important
one nicotine is licensed for use by
children from 12 up by the mhra as a
stop smoking
Aid and it's also licensed for use by
pregnant smokers
um I think we need to be careful in
thinking that nicotine is is
um and the committee on toxicity looked
at this when it looked at and um
e-cigarettes and the toxicity of
e-cigarettes and it looks specifically
at nicotine and didn't conclude that
there was significant concern around
adolescent use sufficient for it to give
a warning now if you remember in 1948
the year the NHS was founded 82 percent
of men smoked in the 1960s 50 of women
smoked
um you know anecdote isn't evidence but
I I was one of those children who grew
up I smoked in my
um in my primary school I actually
carried on smoking on and off until I
started working for ash you know there
are millions and millions and millions
of smokers
who started as children we did not see
massive neurological damage as a result
of that the fact is it's addictive and
and you know up to two-thirds of
long-term smokers die from cancer
cardiovascular disease respiratory
disease but we need to be careful about
assuming high levels of neurotoxicity in
nicotine in Vapes
okay thank you for that but with respect
we also have the doctor's opinion that
is harmful for children and we do have
to listen to to to both and obviously um
yeah opinions today are very important
um if I could just jump around that with
with what education is available to
children because Dr Stewart's saying
that
um children are not aware of the risk
they're not aware of the challenges
posed by these devices
um I know that you're doing a lot but do
you think the department for Education
should be doing more to support head
teachers in providing them with the
materials that they need to make sure
the children have a full access to
information
um absolutely I mean I would agree with
um with Helen in terms of
um you know the you're all fairly
Immortal when you're a teenager aren't
you
um and and it won't happen for ages and
I can stop before then and I don't think
anybody knows how addicted they are to
something until they attempt to stop
um and I think my experience
um is that the majority of students
haven't attempted to stop it still has
its appeal it's still part of their
their peer group activity and so on so
they don't know the extent to which
they're
addicted to something
um in terms of
um a kind of health program and an
awareness program we come back to the
fact that we actually don't we don't
really know and so it's quite hard to
educate so um you know we had an expert
come in to do assemblies he's reached
out across the county to do that and
where the other Counties have the same
kind of arrangements but there's very
little in terms of follow-up material I
think
um you know it would be helpful to
explore the concept of addiction not
necessarily to to nicotine but the
concept of addiction full stop and that
um that dependency because you know you
could you could connect in with online
gambling which obviously uh draws in and
it's and it's kind of analyzing
um you know why why so many humans are
drawn into
um uh addiction into in various
um forms and so you could include that
with alcohol as well and I think whilst
we don't yet know
um the long-term effects of vaping but
we do know it's a lot safer than smoking
it's quite hard I think to push a really
big Health agenda on a demographic that
feel like they're probably going to live
till they're at least 80 90 and that's
in in 70 years time you know that kind
of thing
um so so that's tricky but I think work
around addiction I think
um another thing that
would be really helpful is that there
are Vape sensors on the market
but they're not cheap and we won't go
into the issue of school budgets but in
terms of schools being able to invest in
Vape sensors that might be something
um you know that could be funded
separately whether there were grants
available to come to install Vape
sensors whereby
um they alert they don't set the fire
alarm off they alert instead that
there's somebody vaping and then of
course we can look into that and so I
think there are a range of things I
think more education maybe a focus
around the you know addiction I was a
smoker in my Mist spent Youth and
um and I use patches to stop that and I
love not being a smoker I love not
having an element of my life not in my
control in terms of dependency and
addiction and it's a great thing
um
anecdotally
um I know a few people who stopped
smoking and then thought I miss nicotine
and started vaping and have now
attempted to stop vaping and are finding
it so much more difficult than stopping
smoking I don't know the extent to which
we have data on that but it would be an
interesting exploration I think that
comes back to you know when you smoke a
cigarette you're smoking a finite amount
um at a particular time and the way
um you know we're set up now in a very
limited number of spaces whereas the
ability to top upon a vape very very
regularly and you know and people in the
living room vaping whilst they're
watching TV and so on is like literally
you know with some people
um you know a fairly constant Top-Up and
I wonder whether that's
increasing the extent which people are
dependent on their nicotine fix I could
say um would probably should avoid
because we're trying to focus on the
so much um
we're really grateful to everybody we
probably should move on
um there's another another guest that we
want to ask or want to ask questions
I'll just just briefly with you Dr
Stewart obviously children not using the
toilets at school it's um
yeah it was a new phenomena
um I I remember people not not doing
that at school but is there a is there
any um in your opinion as a as a
clinician pediatrician is there any
health impact of that and the
retentiveness of children not going to
the toilet when they're at school
um yes there is there's increased risk
of urinary tract infections particularly
um and also problems with continents in
the long run as well so yeah definitely
absolutely yeah
when you've got to go you got to go and
you've got to go see what I did there
yeah
this is not just thrown together
um okay right lorenia Caster thank you
so much for for coming today uh Dr Helen
Stewart thank you very much Deborah
Arnett from Ash as always thank you very
much we're just going to take a 60
second break to change panel and then
we'll be back in order
the proceeding is currently suspended
Okay order order we are back with our
second panel and uh We've you've you've
been listening to our first panel we
have John Dunn director general of the
UK vaping industry Association the UK
via and we have uh Marcus Saxton
chairman of the independent British Vape
trade Association the
ibvta and
appreciate your time I know you've been
sitting listening to that evidence we've
done our decorations I wonder whether
you would like to do say your
organizations start with you Marcus yeah
for me
um
what I'd like to announce is that I also
choose the executive from the UK's
leading Vape businesses as well
which is business called Totally Wicked
locally Wicked correct okay and uh Mr
Dunn
um subject to my my role as director
general of the UK via also a managing
director of different Group which is a
consulting company
um that consults and Brands looking to
enter the UK Market okay and UK Bia does
have uh links with the tobacco industry
correct we have over 106 member
companies four of which
um are tobacco-controlled Brands yes
okay but they're board members correct
um they are four of 36 full board
members yes
so you've heard the evidence this
morning that's been given uh you've
heard from a head teacher we've talked
about the impact on schooling and alarms
being set off and exams impacted we've
heard about children with asthma we've
heard about
um children being retentive and not
going to the toilet at school
um
heard quite a lot of interesting stuff
this morning haven't we
absolutely make you feel does it make
you feel good about your industry no um
actually this is something that we've
been pushing for for well over three
years one of the issues that we've
highlighted is the fact that and has
been talked about earlier on that these
products have been sold in inappropriate
locations there's also very little
um Financial penalties for those
retailers called selling to minors a
recent study done by one of our members
Arcus compliance actually found that
very few trading standards groups are
implementing fines and as an example
um a group of 12 cities with five and a
half million people the combined fines
over three years total 2100 pounds we
also had a case recently where a court
fined a store 26 pounds for selling Vape
to a 14 year old now as an association
we've called for Extreme Action to be
taking on that we want to see fines
increase to a minimum of ten thousand
pounds per instance and we want to see
all Vape retailers and Distributors
licensed to sell these products and that
licensing has to include Robo stage
verification processes but also has to
include the fact that they only stock
legitimate licensed products these we
think are reasonable things for the
industry to do if the industry isn't
going to object to it I don't see why
the government can't do it if you look
at what Ireland did recently they're
bringing in a bill that will bring in 4
000 Euro fines but they're tacking on a
prison sentence for those retailers
selling to young people now I think
that's a huge step forward and it's
something that the government should
look at here
okay so you're calling for
you're calling for tougher regulation of
yourself absolutely one of the things
that as an organization that we do is we
hire a third party company to test our
members three times a year we've done
that for over five years now and all of
those results are given to our trading
standards part of booking Missouri
trading standards to understand how you
know how businesses are for instance you
know allowing some of these transactions
to go through because we are not at 100
um and that's really given us a lot of
insights in how young people are getting
these products but I've gone out on
trade trading standards raids I've gone
and and seized illegal products
um and it's ridiculous how easy it is
for young people to get these products
because if there's no disincentive for
retailers to do it those small majority
of uh you know retailers that frankly
don't care who they sell the products to
are going to continue on to do what
they're doing it sounds like you know
from what you're saying it sounds like
you you very much accept there's a
problem here oh I think I think nobody
can say there's not a problem right um
you know but it is illegal for anybody
under the age of 18 to buy Vapes in this
part in in this country and it's illegal
for anybody to buy a vape for anybody
under the age of 18. but we have
highlighted many different things
um one of the things that we brought to
the attention of the government is the
fact that
um non-nicotine Vapes are not subject to
regulation in fact a five-year-old can
legally go out and buy a non-nicotine
vape under the current legislation we
feel that all vaping products should be
brought under the same legislation the
second thing is that the mhra who
regulates nicotine versions of Vapes
does not look at things like packaging
they do not look at things like the
design of the products and I brought one
to the attention of the MH array at a
meeting about a year and a half ago that
was in the shape of a lollipop and it
had lolly in the name but this had mhra
approval now again we think that's
ridiculous but the mhri is not
sanctioned to look at those two areas
okay so that so we accept this problem
but so in 2020 you said in a report
there was Quotes no evidence of
widespread under eight Vape use in the
UK but that there was no room for
complacency so something's changed in
three years absolutely there's a lot
changed um one of the reasons that we're
seeing a Resurgence in the popularity of
disposables is the fact that legislation
was changed in the U.S that left a
loophole open for for sealed devices and
manufacturers in China where all of
these devices are coming from
um saw a huge opportunity now the UK is
the second largest market for Vaping
products Russia being the third and this
is why we saw an increase also the fact
uh the use of social media for instance
like Tick Tock
um you know that's regulated in this
country to an extent I've seen the
adverts yeah but it's attractive exactly
they're presented in a very attractive
light exactly reminds me of the
Marlborough Marlborough man on the horse
exactly but the ASA is actually going to
come out some guidance next month
they've already contacted contacted
myself for our support which we will
give but we feel that there's a lot more
can be done about the use of social
media specifically Tick Tock which has a
really low age demographic we also need
to look at where these products are
being sold I think our previous speakers
talked about chicken shops and pizza
shops absolutely agree those products
should not be sold these are an adult
age-gated product and they should only
be sold in retailers where people can
either buy cigarettes or a special a
specialty vape shop that understands why
these products exist and understand how
to
um
you know use a age verification
processes okay
so Mrs Saxon just wanted to give you a
chance to come in here
based on what you've heard this morning
um you know your your members and you on
their behalf including the one that you
you told us that you you're connected to
you share the view that regulation
should change dramatically I certainly
think regulation should change and it's
got the opportunity to change but I do
think as you've heard this morning it's
really important to understand the
negative consequences that could be
associated with putting in place the
wrong regulation right so what we would
what could that be so just to put into
context Deborah spoke earlier on about a
black market and an illicit trade so by
our estimates if you add up the total
legitimate trade and the illicit trade
within the UK that could be Circa 4
billion pound category roughly
two-thirds of that market is represented
by the black or illicit Market that's a
really important point that we have at
the table to understand whatever
regulation we put in place and as the
Australian model proved is if you don't
effectively regulate you will allow that
market to thrive and where we're hearing
analysis of products that includes
chemicals that are absolutely not
regulated are oversized and age
verification protocols around
non-existent or certainly flouted we
think there's a distinctive link to that
area of the trade and a lot of the
issues that are going on that doesn't
mean that there's not the opportunity to
educate further to restrict access at
border and yeah but you can you can
regulate but then it comes down to
enforcement absolutely and that was one
of the points I was going to say educate
restrict access both at the border and
in terms of who can sell these products
and enforcement in a much more joined up
fashion that it is today but it's
absolutely critical that we think very
carefully about how we enact these to
ensure that these don't get into the
hands of views but do enable the UK
Market that's been the most effective in
terms of Tobacco Control to continue to
thrive as it had done since 2008. so
you're you're both sort of calling for
this extra regulation but why do you
remind me of the AI companies on the
hill in Washington calling for
regulation which sounds great but I
can't help but wonder whether they're
doing it because because they'd rather
they'd rather do it than have it done to
them
um your your industry would you agree at
the moment is taking a pounding
in public in public opinion would you
agree we do but of the representatives
of that industry are more part of it
anyway so what I'd say is as we point
out we've got many hundreds of members
that were founded their business on the
base of being a smoker ours was exactly
that a 20 smoker a day in his early 40s
found a transformative product that
genuinely enabled him to transform his
life many of our members and many of the
businesses worked tirelessly to ensure
that the right products are sold in
their shop to the right people and that
is what enables many people to come in
and access the right products that are
regulated get the right advice to help
them quit smoking there is unfortunately
a much growing area and I've just given
the Quantum of what I think that
represents but unfortunately is
capitalizing commercially on the
opportunity to flout all the good work
that's gone on the regulation that
exists and that's the area that we must
Target not at the expense of those that
are doing exactly what they should do
that is helping this country eradicate
smoking a quick question from Dr Johnson
and then we're going to Paul blomfield
you said at the beginning
[Music]
to football with little ads little girls
look up to footballers they watch them
in there running around in their shirts
and they they admire them and they want
to be like them you've talked a lot
about the importance of responsible
advertising
do you think the little boys and girls
going to watch Blackburn Rovers and
seeing Totally Wicked advertised on a
Sportsman's shirt
when they go to the stadium called the
Totally Wicked Stadium
that they are being Advocate that you
are effectively advertising your
products to Children quite the opposite
actually responsible white the opposite
actually what we believe in in
Lancashire which is where Batman Rovers
and our business are based is actually
one of the highest smoking prevalence
rates in the whole of the country we
believe that everyone that we can drive
awareness to about the relative safety
of vaping versus smoking is actually
someone who's going to benefit from that
the fact that we happen to have our name
on the shirts is not on this shirt for
miners yes I appreciate the point that
they might see their Heroes on the field
but actually educating people around the
role of vaping to try and eradicate
smoking which is again is in the highest
area of that particular county is a
really important message it also enables
us to support the local club that came
to us originally to ask for our support
at a time of need and actually we
brought the two things together and we
think very carefully and work tirelessly
with them to ensure that we position
that in the right way and run smoking
cessation clinics actually at the site
when we have people along and we age
verified people at the points as well
you think you'd dispute the idea that
walking up to the Totally Wicked Stadium
as a boy or girl of 12 or 13. seeing The
Branding of a stadium walking into the
shop into this into the football ground
seeing children the young men on the
field they're Heroes as you describe
them running around the pitch with
Totally Wicked emblazoned across their
chest and then coming out past the
Totally Wicked shop on site has no
impact on children without children's
thoughts on the your brand at all if
anything I hope it would drive awareness
to the fact that over 5000 cases of
Youth being hospitalized due to passive
smoke per year actually it might drive
awareness about the relative safety of
vaping for their parents to potentially
adopt that and make a life-changing
decision to switch to vaping if they saw
our store they would not get Across the
Threshold because we wouldn't let it
under 18 into our stores
first thing you're advertising it to
children in
Illinois not so what I'm saying is
factually I think the fact that anyone
out there who is a smoker that sees our
brand very subtly but sees our brand
right at the sports Stadium hopefully
might drive some education to see the
relative safety of vaping versus smoking
I don't think in any way in quite the
opposite we put it in front of children
to encourage them to vape at all
okay so you don't you don't you think
there are more 11 to 15 year old smokers
who will stop by seeing the advertising
at Blackburn Rovers then there will be
young children attracted to to emulate
their Heroes and and take it up I don't
have evidence to back either of that up
as probably you don't but I appreciate
your points around awareness but what we
believe is any smoker that gets
awareness to vaping is a better
awareness than not
have to disagree on that okay Paul
Bloomfield
Mr Dunn
um you've acknowledged there's an
enormous problem
created by your industry
don't you think it's possibly a bit
convenient that you come along to us
this morning and argue that the
regulation should be focused on
retailers
knowing that uh trading standards
haven't got the capacity to
reinforcement and on social media
it's great diversion tactic
don't you think there's actually a
product with a problem with your
products that you should look at no
absolutely not these products have been
around well over 15 years they are the
most successful way that adults quit
smoking here in the UK we've now got
three I'm sorry 4.2 million uh people
vaping successfully that were primarily
um ex-smokers why do you think it's
necessary to produce flavors
like sweets and to Market them with
cartoon characters well you're not
supposed to be able to do that and this
is why one of the things that we've
called on is yeah none of your members
and only your members produce any
products which are flavored in the way
that's been described by our previous we
have an extensive code of conduct that
our members sign up to and we don't use
cartoon characters on our products but
we do all the sort of flavors that we've
heard from other Witnesses well flavors
are extremely important
um to adults that's one of the reasons
why vaping is so successful we bear
I'll give you an example I'm almost 60
years of age I like Jen for instance I
have a strawberry candy flush gin at
home that comes in a pink bottle I have
a bubble gum flavored gin
important the flavors are important to
young people but should they emulate
food products no they shouldn't and
according to the law that is not allowed
um but this is one of the reasons why
we've called for the mhra to be given
the teeth and given the powers to look
at product design and packaging before
they approve any products a lot of the
products that you're talking about that
come into this country illegally are not
subject to those same regulations and
one of the problems when I talk to
trading standards is they say they're
under re resource they don't have the
facility to do that and this is why we
are calling for the licensing fee and
we're calling for the fines to be done
not only on retailers but also on
Distributors bringing in these illegal
products and all of those resources
should be ring fenced and given to
trading standards
um you know talking about some of these
these Distributors we provide
intelligence to both trading standards
and to border Force we've reported the
same wholesaler in one city 25 times and
no action has been taken on that case
the industry is not here to sell to
Children the industry is not here to to
hide from the fact that some Road
retailers and Distributors are bringing
in products that are unsuitable I'm sure
we'll come back to some of those points
um Mr Saxton I mean you used a different
diversionary tactic you said the problem
wasn't necessarily social media or
retailers you said it was enforcement
and you made the case that
um the problem is if we regulate vaping
it'll just drive towards a black market
people sort of black market
isn't that exactly what big tobacco
argued about smoking when we tried to
regulate cigarettes
um there may be some parallels to that
but that's categorically not what we're
trying to advocate here I think going
back to your point on flavors I think
some of the examples you use in the
media have a really implicit role to
play here that many United submitted
some to the clerk ahead of this session
if you saw them that are used are not
regulated products on the UK Market
anyone that's using names that simulate
food or drink should be targeted and
prosecuted by those food and drink under
existing regulation they would not be
allowed anyone that flouts with flavor
names that are so ridiculous or
emulating those food or drink again
wouldn't it be no reputable business
that would do that and those should
absolutely be banned having said that
the role of flavors if any of you have
been a smoker is absolutely critical to
enabling a successful quit attempt you
will addicted to tobacco and you may
start your journey on Tobacco to be
successful and there is now data that
shows over 80 percent of successful quit
attempts are made by people moving away
from those flavors that they're actually
addicted to to flavors that are furthest
away from that for obviously reasons
that that's where their dependency is so
please if you can get across there isn't
a really critical role for flavors for
aiding a smoker's quit attempt the
examples that you give and many of them
are actually examples where they are not
reputable businesses not regulated that
are finding themselves on the market but
I do agree that must be tightened up and
no reputable business would sell those
or create those today
smoker I didn't smoke cigarettes because
I thought they tasted nice it was
because it was a nicotine addict
but let me let me come to
the the argument you're making and
you've both made that um and you're
making it again now and that the value
of your products
is in getting people off smoking
let's do my own back to when the
tobacco products directive was being
discussed 10 years ago
there were two routes
that were being looked at
one was that the product should be
licensed
for exactly that purpose that you
describe
the other was that it would have a more
light touch regulation as a Leisure
product
why did The Vaping industry so strongly
resist licensing
for me licensing is really clear it's an
extremely laborious process and actually
the products that are already extremely
effective for smokers to gain access to
actually by the time they'd gone through
that process and out the other side
would likely be out of date and the most
important thing is if you look at any
SME that's set up a purposeful business
in this sector to enable smokers to move
away from their addiction you will find
that they would not be able to afford
the fees that would be charged through a
licensing process and actually what
would you find is a negative consequence
the only people that would be able to
afford access to go to those licensed
products would be big tobacco businesses
that are causing the issue in the first
instance but then secondly claiming to
actually be solving it and that's the
reason the access to products today and
has been demonstrated through the
reduction in smokers and the growth in
Vapors up to the recent single-use
product it's been extremely effective
outside of Licensing isn't it true that
if it had been licensed as the sort of
medicinal product that you you describe
it would have been a much smaller Market
I think there would have been much
smaller uptake I think we'd still be a
much smaller opportunities for you as an
industry much smaller opportunities to
move the transition of smokers with two
out of three people if used directed by
the manufacturer's instructions will die
there would be much less opportunity to
convert those across yes I agree
we've heard from previous witnesses that
[Music]
um
well vaping is more addictive
than smoking
do you know what the proportion of
nicotine in your products is compared
with cigarettes
yeah so I don't have any evidence on the
former so I'd be interested if there is
any that's been submitted on the former
but again the media in this instance
tend to cite a single product which
contains 20 mix per ml or 40 Megs across
2 mil which is typically what a
single-use product will have to one
cigarette that's 12 mg the important
distinction here is a packet of 20
cigarettes will contain roughly 250
milligrams of nicotine that will take
about 150 to 300 Puffs to get through
a single-use device therefore with 40
milligrams compared to 250 milligrams
take about the same time to go through
so the relative nicotine needs to be
really importantly positioned a packet
of 20 actually has far greater nicotine
than a single-use product with 40
milligrams in why do you think your
product's more addictive
I don't have any evidence to that effect
in fact actually to the contrary because
the efficiency of a combustible
cigarette to drive nicotine into the
system so my understanding is far more
effective than a disposable Vape where
the nature of the puffing is far
different to how you would with a
combustible cigarette so I certainly
don't have evidence to support that
myself
uh Mr Dunham final question
um as the chair uh pointed out your
board includes representatives of
British American Tobacco Philip Morris
International Imperial tobacco or
Imperial Brands as they are now Japan
tobacco International
don't you think that it would be a
reasonable assumption that what's really
happened here
is that faced with
the inevitable decline of smoking
because of the regulation taking place
internationally
big tobacco just saw an opportunity to
use vaping
to create a new generation of nicotine
edits well I disagree on that if if you
look at how vaping has developed in this
country it has been primarily as as
Marcus pointed out independent companies
the tobacco industry has only gotten
into the Vape industry because it became
so big
um and they have a commercial interest
to doing so as an organization when we
formed
um the idea around our organization was
that we were inclusive of everybody that
was involved we bring all stakeholders
together
um very similar to what say cop 27 did
with environmental issues we have a lot
of robust uh and stringent rules within
our organization each company pays
exactly the same in membership fees so
we are not reliant on any large
donations from tobacco companies each of
our each of our 36 board members has one
vote
um so again if you look at we have four
tobacco companies and they're vaping
Brands we have 36 currently board
members and that number is increasing
every single month as new companies join
the organization so we have very aware
of the influence that tobacco could have
within our organization but we feel to
preclude them would be would be not a
good idea what opportunities would make
tobacco have to
sell nicotine to basically sell their
products if it wasn't for Vaping as
smoking declined well if the nicotine is
in many different products you've got
Patches you've got gums you've got these
new pouches that are coming onto the
market as well as vapor smoking
cessation products yes absolutely
um so they have every opportunity to try
and sell nicotine products but what's
really important is how successful
vaping has been
um if vaping is kind of enjoyable as
recreational Pursuit why not just
produce something which has benign not
some of the appalling stuff that we've
heard about antifreeze but just has
benign content
um but doesn't include
a deeply addictive product nicotine
and in that particular instance clearly
where the business was founded and where
it continues to be is if you remove
nicotine from a product and you are as
you said a previous smoker you will have
a materially failed attempt to remove
off the product that's killing you so
it's as simple as that we have to have
products that have nicotine in them
no we don't enable people to make the
transition that the UK has been such a
leader in across the world forum and
that's absolutely implicit if it does
not contain nicotine given with the
right advice and Direction with the
right product then effectively we will
for smoking cessation but clearly the
problem that we're looking at is that
vaping is developing to a whole layer of
young people who have never been smokers
in that particular instance that's where
I say it's important to understand that
really poignant context to then say how
do we tackle the issue of how people
getting access to them and I think we
can happily talk longer against that but
yeah very good very good questioning uh
Rachel
thank you Mr Saxon you've been very
clear that your advertising has been
about public health so why use your
products for advertising as opposed to
putting Public Health messages across
shirts of heroes or across a stadium why
are you trying to promote your business
instead because I think it's really
important that we are a business that is
endeavoring to help people stop smoking
we're a commercial entity and therefore
we want those smokers to recognize our
brand and all the tireless work that we
put into our stores particularly to give
the right advice for those particular
people I think if it was a public health
message alone which we would Advocate as
a side is I think education is really
important but that's not for us a
commercial entity where we're looking
for those smokers to access our stores
to gain that advice it is about the
commercialization of your product
because clearly we know from what's
happened around cigarette advertising is
that when you remove that advertising
that obviously small smoking rates have
fallen so this is clearly a commercial
Venture for yourself so so the
questioning from my colleague was
correct in saying that you are trying to
promote your Brands which enables a new
generation of no no which enables
smokers currently who are nicotine
addicts to make a transition to a safer
alternative and that's the really
important point there are six million
people still taking combustibles two or
three which will die if used accurately
by manufacturer's instructions we are a
commercial entity that is looking to
attract those people to our brand
because we do age verify we only stock
regulated products all our store staff
are National Center of smoking cessation
trained and will ensure that they get
the right advice for a successful quit
attempt that's how the whole context
needs to be put together okay I think
you've contradicted yourself there very
clearly in the light of the evidence
around plane packaging and the impact
that has had on public health and also
the importance of Public Health
messaging as opposed to advertising a
product and we've seen the impact of
that because the public health measures
that this place has had to take in in
order to move people away I think it's
really clear the role that we're trying
to play commercially around converting
smokers to a much safer alternative and
I think that is absolutely consistent
with what I've tried to deliver today I
think it's I think it's also good to
point out that as vaping companies we
are not permitted to make Health claims
on our product
um the tpd the crpo does not allow us to
do that and one of the suggestions that
we have made to government is for them
to come out with some pre-approved
switching messages that they are
comfortable with around vaping and allow
commercial organizations to use those
but currently we are not allowed to make
Health claims on our products
I didn't so you're saying on your
products but on putting that on on
footballs as shirts clearly
um that would be the case now if I can
ask
the Don why you're wanting to induce
children into addictive forming
behaviors because clearly we've heard
from the evidence of the first panel the
scale in which children are taking up
vaping so I wonder if you can answer
that question well first of all we're in
in no way trying to get young people and
children to use our products at all this
is why we're calling for robust uh
enforcement of the current legislation
we have a lot of wonderful laws in this
country but unless they are enforced
unless there is a financial penalty for
breaking those rules then you can make
all the laws you want but they won't be
followed and this is why we're looking
at punitive charges on those retailers
and Distributors and brands that are
flouting the law that's where the
biggest problem is it's not the the
companies that are doing it the right
way that are following the regulations
that are testing all of their products
and marketing them in a responsible way
and this is why we need to Target the
issue where the issue is
in favor of plane packaging you're in
favor of the removal of the different
shapes of vaping products you're in
favor of the removal of flavors and the
the removal of the different colors as
as an industry absolutely not um the
first thing in regards to plane
packaging there's already a lot of
misinformation around the relative
safety of vaping and Monarch smokers and
amongst the general public we feel that
if you were to go down the lines of
plane packaging all you're trying to do
is reinforce the fact that these
products are in some way as bad as
smoking which is not the case you know
we're trying to encourage do you believe
it's the industry's job to make the
public health case or do you think it is
governments I think it's a combination
of both okay I am
um I think within with regards to
Flavors flavors are one of the reasons
why vaping has been so popular and we
did a recent survey of 4 000 Vapors and
said what would happen if flavors were
restricted or banned and 33 percent of
those said they would go back to smoking
now if we look at the current rates of
4.2 million that's one and a half
million people that potentially could go
back to smoking if flavors are banned or
restricted surely that's the wrong way
to go failure of our smoking cessation
uh pathway not not a reason not to do it
this is not a toy this is not to move
this is something to move move people
off a off a drug that is killing people
it's the biggest preventable killer in
our country today and you are selling
your your clients are selling flavors
that are attracting children absolutely
love these flavors have been around for
well over a decade I've been in this
industry when there was 20 000 people
vaping these flavors are not new
disposables are not new they have always
been that low entry point into vaping
um if you look at the transactions for
uh for disposables at the moment we just
did a survey of five now sorry a half a
million transactions and the average
median age for those sales was 36.3
years of age
um so you know to say that these
products are only attracting children is
is incorrect I don't believe I said that
the record will show I said you are
selling products that are attractive to
Children sorry Rachel do carry no no
that's fine I mean it's very clear from
the industry that your interest clearly
is
um the profit motive it always has been
and to be able to accrue to another
generation as my colleague said of
people who are using your products into
an addictive lifestyle obviously means
that then you secure for the long term
the the profit margins that you want to
generate off these products so you I
take it would have no objection
whatsoever to the taxation
um suggestions that came from Ash this
morning which would deter many people
from even taking up those products I
probably wouldn't object to a raise in
price what I object to is a taxation on
the product that would
um probably turn uh smokers that are in
lower deprived areas the opportunity to
take those I think Deborah made a great
point there Iran about the tank size of
the products so what we've suggested is
that the two milliliter maximum tank
size should be abolished and products
should be allowed to go up to in the
region of 10 milliliters that would then
take the price of that product from that
pocket money level of four or five
pounds up towards in the region of 15
pounds
but what it also does is it gives the
adult smoker who's choosing to buy that
product
um a device that lasts five times longer
than the one they spend five pounds on
and the second effect would be is eighty
percent of the uh the the the products
will be off of the market so instead of
five devices you would have one which is
easier to recycle
and just on your other formal Point
Rachel probably in a better position to
answer as a leader in one of the UK Vape
businesses as well as other members I
take total exception to the point that
you think that we're generating a new
generation of nicotine addicts many of
the founders of these businesses
including my own were killing themselves
through an addiction to a combustible
cigarette that factually and other
equivocally is at least of a magnitude
that Deborah said 90 to 95 percent
less safe than a vaping product we start
our business and yes there's commercials
that need to come off the back of it
otherwise you would not find so many
vaping stores that exist because they
are looking to generate a livelihood but
the fact that they saw a transformative
product themselves that benefited
themselves they can therefore sell
products in the right way to adults with
the right education and take absolute
exception to the point that you think
there's some form of profit motive for
these individual businesses solely going
on behind this this is a very purpose
sector with people that set up their
businesses behind a very transformative
product that aided them to make a
successful quit attempt so just to
conclude
um so you would be very comfortable
because of your strong Public Health
credentials so you present them to us if
products were just available say from
licensed pharmacies as opposed to other
High Street retail outlets absolutely
not because I think that would
absolutely fly in the favor but there's
no surprise because it would fly in the
face of the fact that the reason these
products have done so well is because it
is regulated we're calling for further
regulation to tighten up what's now been
an extreme growth in single-use products
but actually if you put them into those
environments like New Zealand and
Australia is telling us the perception
of the public is that actually where it
can buy tobacco freely anywhere The
Vaping product is up to 95 safer is
licensed than through a pharmacy it
makes absolutely no sense and the
negative consequence of considering such
a thing will take us backwards years
there's Morris just very um quick one
for me um section I think you said
earlier on about the Australian model so
your argument which is that we need more
regulation we need a complete ban is
that the Australian model didn't work
Australia only banned
um vaping two years ago so what's the
evidence about this failure of the
Australian model in terms of driving the
black market and or other consequences
and I think to your very point I'd need
to provide evidence separately to the
committee around specifically because it
is early days I think the bit that I'd
draw sense to is to allow freely tobacco
to be available we're not consistently
like New Zealand have done alongside
that is limit where that is available
and then put vaping in the right context
perhaps absolutely your knowledge have
have as Australia seen a growth in a
Black Market anecdotally yes but I'd
want to make sure I've got the right
good news to provide is it possible for
you for you to sort of present us with
let me take that separately and I
wouldn't have that with me today but let
me take that separately Endeavor to
provide it just
just go back to Rachel Master's point
you know your question paraphrasing was
that you would take no exception of them
only therefore being sold through
licensed pharmacies right here's your
question
um so so if you are highly motivated to
uh to move off tobacco products nicotine
tobacco products then what would be the
problem in going to a pharmacy there's
lots of pharmacies
what would be the problem well lots lots
of pharmacies do stock vaping products
um but I think it's important to make
these products available wherever
tobacco products are sold because in in
the most part it's smokers are not
making a conscious decision they don't
walk into a store and go oh I'm going in
there to buy an e-cigarette it's
generally a a spontaneous decision in
the first place to go do I buy a pack of
cigarettes or do I try something
different I mean that's that's why it's
very important to have those products
available where consumers are buying new
evidence that it's a spontaneous
decision so they go in and they think I
may buy a packet of cigarettes today but
I may buy a vape and there's literally
as spontaneous as that so I might go I
might buy a Yorkie bar I might buy a
whisper but no I might buy a back of
cigarettes but I might buy a vape can
you could you evidence that to us I have
speaking I've spoken to thousands of
vapors over the years no we can't deal
in anecdotals we want if you're evidence
to suggest to back that up we would love
to see it
points is just whenever that product is
available
to John's point I can't evidence that
which is why I wouldn't cite it but
actually for me it's about whenever that
is available a tobacco product that is
going to categorically kill two out of
three users we must have a regulated
vaping product available for them to
make that choice whether that's
immediately or over time with the right
education that sits behind it that is
what the UK has seen and proven to be
able to be successful in and that's the
bit we've got to stay focused on right
well let's uh let's close with the
doctor Dr Caroline Johnson thank you uh
um I wanted to ask you a question about
you talked about you wouldn't be happy
for the money to be provided as a
medical prescription product from
pharmacist but actually currently the
NHS don't provide any on prescription
and perhaps the reason for that is with
the NHS has quite high standards that
you have to meet in order to make
something a prescription product is the
fact that after all this time there
aren't any available energy prescription
despite your
claims that these are saving lives left
right and Center is that not a sign that
perhaps there are more significant
safety concerns no if you've got any
evidence to support that then I would
clearly be interested in seeing it what
I do have is our members work with over
50 smoking cessation groups around the
country
they clearly are advocating successfully
as part of an overall series of
possibilities and interventions for
smokers that they are very happy to
support vaping as the most successful
quit Aid so my evidence would be there's
already evidence out there that says
they are clearly safer and smoking
cessation experts in local boroughs and
councils are using vaping as a directive
tool that is the most the NHS has failed
really in getting doctors to prescribe
these to the people that have them for
free I think we've certainly failed in
educating people I know there's been
some horror stories around a GP that was
in the press that suggested that their
son should move to cigarettes rather
than Vape which I think is absolutely
terrible and if that's where we've got
to there's further education that must
be driven into the system before we
think about anything further but I would
agree education is key I think I find it
very interesting now that you say that
there hasn't been a device that's gone
through the medical licensing process
according to
NHS well the only the only product
that's successfully gotten through was
brought through by British American
Tobacco and it went to Market and failed
miserably it went bankrupt within the
first year
what I was saying is that Antonio
subscription the NHS when it asks
doctors to prescribe things I should
recognize mention I'm a doctor it does
go through several high levels of safety
checks and I find it interesting that
you you know these various products
haven't made it to prescription if they
are indeed such a safe and life-saving
product
um the I wanted to ask Marcus about the
ibvta annual standards you talk about
regulation and self-regulation
um what penalties do you have in place
for met your members what code of
practice do you have in place for your
members to ensure that they maintain the
standards that are set the main standard
for us is that we don't accept anyone
who's got influence or control from
tobacco so that is the criteria
effectively that we would hold them to
account on they wouldn't be able to join
our association because we believe again
there's a conflict of interest around
what our purpose category is trying to
do versus what their motives are what's
your reaction to members that break the
law
um if we were found evidence of that
then from our perspective I'm sure as a
board we bring that to the table and
depending on what that was if it was
around age verification and consistently
flouting and we'd educated them we still
did that then they wouldn't be welcome
within our association
and the producer of Elf bar so they were
the new Association uh they're UK green
fun Alliance as they're called limited
is yes that's not the Chinese
manufacturer that's their UK entity okay
but in February this year Morrison's and
Sainsbury's and other stores removed elf
bars from their shelves on mass the
reason for that is that the products
that were being sold in these
supermarkets did not meet the UK
regulations they were illegal products
so what action did your Trade
Organization take in response to one of
your members breaking the law important
point they actually joined is actually
just after that period that was found
and what we believe that as the biggest
single product and brand within this
Marketplace what actually we felt better
was to bring them into our stewardship
be able to advise and direct with all
the advice that we've got to bring that
product which as you know came back into
regulation actually far more effectively
than it could have done had we not given
that advice and Direction and now we're
working with them much more closely to
ensure that lots of the areas like
responsibility around age verification
and recycling actually we can direct
them and Steward them far more
effectively within the association than
outside of it and that's I think what
their responsibility is you're you're
happy to take them on even though
they've broken the law because you think
they will be less likely to break the
law on your umbrella that's the single
biggest brand in the UK I think it's
critical that they come within our
stewardship and enable us to come back
into compliance which is what they did
extremely quickly and from here on in we
can advise them within our associate
Asian rather than outside of what sort
of Regulation do you have on corporate
transparency because you've got the um
we talked about the the UK arm is part
of your organization but I Miracle is
pretty nebulous organization isn't it
what forms of information do they have
to have on transparency we just look at
them as the UK business and we would
attempt to understand what their
Upstream is but as you say there's only
so far we can go as an association
that's not for profit and therefore we
do do our due diligence as effectively
as we can
okay how many Vapors are there in the
country now do you think would you have
estimates of that uh the last numbers
were 4.3 I suspect they've probably gone
up by at least another million
throughout that was in 2022 to where we
are today that is an estimate 5 million
yeah I suspect it is in that sort of
magnitude around about five million
people according to the government
figures there were 10.7 million smokers
uh in 20 000 2007 when these products
were first launched onto the market and
6.6 million uh last a year of which
another million have died that leaves
you with around 3 million uh smokers
that you could have potentially helped
equip within those figures so the other
two million nearly nearly getting on for
half your Market are people who didn't
smoke to start with
do you accept that uh the estimate I'm
not quite I think we might have lost a
million somewhere in your calculations
there that's right 6.6 6.6 that have
died 6.6 and a million is with F4 5.6
yeah noon 10 10 10 and a half to six and
a half is four from Seven millions and
then a million have died that's 5.6 no
6.6 no sorry if you had 10 and you've
now got six yeah stop there then you had
then then you've lost four
right no no there was always six at the
point we had 4.3 so when there's 4.3
million Vapors which was last cited in
2022 there was still six million smokers
but a million people have died so that's
now five million smokers
and you had but I'm getting lost in fact
no I'm I'm being shot straightforward so
at the time at which there was 4.3
million Vapors cited in the ass survey
in 2022 there was Circa 6.6 million
sorry no they also know five million
Vapors sorry my fax is a 6.6 million
smokers and there is 4.3 million Vapors
that's where I was standing in 2020.
I'm suggesting to you that those five
more five million people that smoke are
vaping are not all former smokers okay
using to take the maths add up in the
way you've described just to be really
clear factual evidence in 2022 the app
survey 6.6 million smokers 4.3 million
Vapors then as I pointed out we moved to
an estimate that said there might be
another million so therefore there's
still six million smokers yeah and even
if you said a million have died there's
five million still left so I think at
the moment what we're doing is are you
suggesting that there could be other
people than with smokers moving into
these products there could be but I
think we've got to wait for the evidence
to come forward and then we need to
understand who is it are these youths to
the very discussion today or are the
adults that would have already otherwise
what I'm suggesting to you is that a
large part of your Market is made up by
people who've never smoked and that you
know that and that's the estimate that
you're giving the factual evidence at
last point of 2022 didn't point to that
over 90 percent of the 4.3 million
smokers were either current smokers that
were using vaping in Jewel or were
previous smokers so that's the evidence
we've got that was the last cited 90 of
the people who are vaping now are former
smokers of the 4.3 cited in 2022 what
I've estimated and said to you to your
very point is has there been a growth
beyond that last sighted data yes there
could have been you think you've helped
0.7 million people to quit smoking since
last year I think there will be a
considerable number that will have done
but do I accept your point the negative
consequence of this that we're debating
today is how do we ensure these get into
the hands of smokers and don't gain
access unless people are very well
educated to say that these are the risks
associated with vaping and if you make
an informed choice of an over 18 year
old to access vaping versus smoking that
is then a very different discussion
yeah so we have got a problem with
children vaping and I think people would
accept that yeah do you think it's I'm
gonna ask both of you this do you think
it's society's job to protect adult
smokers from their bad choices that they
made perhaps many years ago or do you
think that Society has in government has
a greater responsibility to protect
children from the harm of these devices
and from taking up an addiction which
will cost them money and potentially
cost them their health I think both
because to Deborah's point I think a lot
of those habits were formed when you
were young so I think to your very Point
absolutely it's about the youth of today
to educate and make sure they don't get
access to these products which is what
we so vehement and passionate around but
it's certainly a much more complex
debate than just single-use products
into the hands of views do we think we
have a responsibility for adult smokers
because less than 50 percent of them can
cite that vaping is a safer alternative
absolutely so it's both cohorts I think
that we've got to continue to educate
and help to gain the help that they need
to access these products if they are
smokers today your thoughts John I I
think Deborah summed it up this morning
the prohibition doesn't work
um right education the right position
these products and the right penalties
for those that are flouting the law
those things work prohibition doesn't it
wasn't my question my question was when
the government if the government is
forced to choose between protecting
smokers who are adults protecting
children from vaping which is a
government of great responsibility to do
to protect adults or to protect children
I think they have the the uh they need
to protect the health of every person in
the UK but I don't think they need to be
forced to make a choice between one and
the other there there are robust laws in
place that are not being enforced and
that's what needs to be fixed the
industry uh you know is well versed in
the loopholes that are out there I think
we've raised every single one of them
either with border force with the mhra
or the government directly but no action
is being taken to close those loopholes
and I think that's where it needs to
start the industry and the government
needs to come together to close those
loopholes and make it more difficult for
young people to access these products
okay you wanted to pick up on what you
said a bit earlier about the amount of
nicotine in a cigarette as compared with
because a lot of people ask this
question how does an um how does the
amount of nicotine in a cigarette
compared with the amount of nicotine in
a vaping device a single-use vaping
device of 600 puffs with 40 milligrams
in it so standard British
um disposable Vape
um and
my understanding is that if you compare
the amount of amount in a cigarette that
is is not a reasonable thing to do
because when you're vaping The Vape is
only released when you're inhaling
whereas when you're when you're using a
cigarette you're holding it in your hand
and much of its fleece into the air and
there's um a fair amount of it in fact
my understanding is that where there's
up to 20 milligrams of nicotine in the
cigarette only around 10 is absorbed so
it's only one or two milligrams actually
within a cigarette is that the sort of
figures you'd recognize from from our
scientific evidence
um that's presented to us
um nicotine is absorbed in a different
way in a cigarette than it is in a
vaping device and nicotine and vaping
devices is uh absorbed at a much less
a much less rate also there is no
standard cigarette cigarettes range
anywhere from about seven milligrams up
to 28 milligrams per cigarette so making
that comparison is very difficult and I
think that was pointed out earlier is
but do you accept that when someone is
making a cigarette that they will take
in a smaller proportion well 10
apparently is the standard of the amount
of nicotine that was within that
cigarette whereas if you're having a
vape you're taking a much greater
proportion because you don't have that
time at which you're not sucking on it
effectively no because nicotine is
absorbed in a different way
it is probably worth it
in what way is it it's absorbed
differently first of all lungs it's
absorbed into the lungs how is it
because the particles are different
sizes they're absorbed into the body in
a different way is my understanding but
I'm not I'm not a clinician is what way
is the nicotine
the amount of nicotine that absorbs into
the body in in a specific period of time
is different and as I said I'm not I'm
not a clinician so I your problem is
well absolutely so you're suggesting
that there's a difference so the same
amount of nicotine goes into the lungs
and is it is inhaled but when the same
amount of nicotine is inhaled from a
cigarette less of it is absorbed than
when it is inhaled via vaping devices
that what you're saying and do you have
evidence for this
um I could provide evidence to that yes
a very interesting scenarios thank you
thank you brilliant um just just to
close up interesting they're Totally
Wicked exchange that Caroline had I'm
not not that it's not a description that
is a fact
um of the product The Rovers Blackburn
Rovers had it's their shirt sponsor for
22-23 season is that is that ride yes do
they have it for the 23-24 season yes we
do oh you do okay and when you when you
created that company presumably you you
know you had gone's agency you you
worked on the name of the product
um were you involved at that stage no I
wasn't this was probably I just wondered
what why it was called Totally Wicked
I'll give you the very simple story as
succinctly as I can yeah this was a
smoker smoking 20 a day he was killing
himself as described he found a
transformative product and he wandered
around the streets of Lancashire because
he'd found something so transformative
he passed it around to smokers in that
Lancashire area and a number of them
said crikey what's this it's Totally
Wicked he realized he needed to put a
personality to a brand if he was going
to ultimately get it to stick through
and compete versus big tobacco and the
name literally start from there this
product set was transformative and
Totally Wicked they were adults that
said that absolutely this is my son's 12
and he uses that expression yeah this
goes back to 2008 when the business was
founded so right at the beginning of
this and that might be a crude flage but
in Lancashire it certainly resonated
with lots of millions of smokers just
while we're on the points of further
Evidence it'll be useful if we could
have further evidence on Independent
evidence not anecdotal talk to lots of
people
um of the importance of flavors yes
um in smoking cessation
that would be very helpful okay right
we'll close there so John Dunn uh
director General UK vaping industry
Association at Marcus Saxon chairman of
the independent British Vape trade
Association thank you very much for
there's a robust session it's meant to
be the subjects does strongest emotions
and um and we don't apologize for that
but we do we are grateful for your time
so thanks very much